vous avez toujours voulu savoir si big
foot existe et si les fantômes existent
et ses créatures surnaturelles toujours
autant qu aux caisses et les créatures
surnaturelles tout court existait
aujourd'hui on est sur rec et on joue un
[ __ ] de chasseurs de créatures bras
normal on est dans une [ __ ] carval et
le but c'est de prouver que big foot et
qui secrétaire de [ __ ] de par le mal
qu'ils font flipper les gens existent
voit la toile doute on a 12 ans
apparemment il faut qu'on place les
caméras alors attendez je vais prendre
ce cas alors où sont les caméras elles
sont là hockey atome mais il a pris 6
aux caméras il est allé dans un magasin
gopro il a 10 janvier 18 c'est pourquoi
monsieur on promet de but foot il existe
d'accord il faut voilà n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner je fais aussi régulièrement
des podcasts est parti alors on va pas
poser c'est peut-être caméra hunting art
et à mon avis des gens vont poser une
sonde qu'en france c'est quoi ce bruit à
d'accord on a carrément à part [ __ ] de
cochon comment on fait pour installer
khaimah rak est cependant 70 on a de la
fidh wise hockey dans la nourriture pour
attirer les mousses bien sûr genre big
foot voilà dirais que avec des malabars
houllier un très bon chasseur alors
j'aimerais bien mettre une caméra sur le
cochon comment nous ç aa temps il est où
le
il est où le cochon il s'est barré c'est
un sketch il est où
mais il fait quoi mais revient revient
[ __ ] de cochon je vais te kidnappé bon
gars mais qu'on est le chasseur le moins
crédible de la planète quoi [ __ ] on a
perdu deux cochons voilà on commence ay
permière bon alors on va mettre des
caméras on va mettre des caméras là ok
et de une habitante du coup on va
pouvoir passer à nouveau sur peut-être
là dedans pour attirer les gens mais oui
[ __ ] on est malin bien et le port lay
qui comparent tous plus tard j'aimerais
bien trouver vous mettre son camarade
qu'avec une seule caméra je pense qu'on
va pas trop trouvé big foot tu veux on
n'a vraiment pas trouvé une biche donc
ça crée un peu en fait tous les points
rouges sur la ma place les endroits je
peux mettre des caméras on va mettre le
plus possible mon gars et on va se faire
défoncer hop une de plus c'est déjà une
mission mais de trouver sur quel à
remettre les caméras quoi rien n'est sûr
la nappe vrai je suis sur le point rouge
il est où il est il est là bas je suis
débile voilà [ __ ] on est bien écoutez
je bronze un truc très simple on va
retourner au campement et on va passer
le jour va sortir l'annuel d'autres
fusils long et on va en le port il
estoit au piège de fond est tombée dans
un piège et olympia juillet le combat on
peut parler de plus de 5 on est
tellement baisers aux noms qui me
rassure le port ça aurait été génial
bigfoot y mange quoi ils mangent pas du
kfc mange du porc directement [ __ ] moi
ça on prend le fusil on prend le fusil
l'automne dans la caravane et aux la
plage urbaine au [ __ ] ambiance au max
bordel rien et ça qu'on cherche à garder
c'est ça voyons les épreuves là alors
est-ce qu'on peut accéder à notre caméra
ouais on peut bouger en plus avec ce
trouble est un mec caméra suivante il
n'y a rien on voit rien pas se mentir
camera 3 y a rien du tout cas main quand
il ya cancer ou s'il ya quoi c'est le
cas du bruit ouais mais c'est le port
qui tourne autour de ckoi envahi le but
et où aller le but et puis on va revient
dans la caravane
il est où
il est où le port oui il ya du bruit qui
a fait du bruit à l'ohada il fut pas ce
sport là aujourd'hui faisais mes
activités tous et en vrille carmenère
tôt mais c'est pas où c'est big foot qui
rôde la c1 port il est où ce mvt heiner
müller il en train de saboter la chasse
le conte l on remonte dans la dans la
tour on peut fermer la porte ou pas oui
c'est toujours plus correct rien n'y a
pas de mouvements n'y a rien du tout mec
c'est chaud à part le port hôpital
abeilles alors là alors la [ __ ] de
bord mon pote tu vas au guatemala ont
voulu narguer week-end au port ou quelle
est ta merde là c'est sûr monsieur
harper par big foot il va se ramener les
choux de 68 pour moi lâche et c'est le
port est tranquille cam 5
elle est cassée watts à toulouse c'est
carrément intelligente efficace mais
caméra je suis choquée mais du bruit là
là ya du bruit mec c'est un port c'est
un port c'est un [ __ ] de par kim nous
montre son cul mais c'est pas possible
plus tard demain dans la journée j'avais
tous débuté hier voilà voilà voilà qui
montre qu alors toi avec toi il est où
il est parti là tu vois la nourriture
dossiers comme ça [ __ ] musée parti
voulait pas qu'on retient c'est là où il
y avait les 5° mouillart yard a way
tombe dans un piège mais qui tombe dans
un piège
oui en look on m'a dit je vais lui
mettre une caméra dessus
résumé toi bien servi tout cas je le
déteste salle pas alors du coup caméra
ça que je crois on est sur le port et
oui [ __ ] c'est bon ça franchement si
on reste en surpoids quand on va le
monstre parce que le moi c'est pourquoi
il vous départ je n'ose même pas compter
nombre de fois j'ai dit le mot pendant
cette vidéo toujours rien absence totale
de monstres à écouter ce prono mène
nulle part
ce jeu propose un truc qu'on porte nos
pauses et ses big foot existe va lui
dire bonjour on voit rien on voit rien
c'est terrible mec c'est quoi ce bruit
c'est quoi ce bruit là il ya une caméra
new way on va aller un peu plus loin à
tanger trop vite trouvé semonce là et
mon tout est un peu long il ya en tout
cas à bouger la balle ya un truc à
bouger dans les fougères il ya un bruit
ya un bruit ya un bruit c'est un truc
qui marche
cimpor c'est sûr là qu'on a vu tellement
de porc j'y crois plus de seconde à
hautmont stress apparaissent à port
saint pourçain pas et où est ce que tu
es lo à la cavalerie tanoh femme pam pam
pas d'atacama veuf qui m'attend mais on
va s'y tenir cette voie il m'a tellement
ça c'est pas du tout mais foot c'était
ici au [ __ ] mexes et sérieuse combien
de mois on bat les couilles je dansais
cardin durera jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
je veux rester avec mes porte finalement
ma vie elle était super et comment je
fais pour les capturer ça mange quoi un
alien mike c'est vrai ça je veux bien
mais de la bouffe dans la cage là mais
qu'est ce qui vous qu'est ce qu'ils
mangent sûrement pas des graines ont
gelé ces les graines avec fred chose à
retrouver la liait à catane sera de
manger des graines
outre milan pour lui tu avais l'année
n'est pas comme quoi il vaut il ya les
caméras il va pas mais c'est sûr nous
rassurer nous reste 26 balles mais
vision va pour y aller moi pour y aller
[ __ ] j'ai quand même des doutes
s'évacue vers cette peur mais un peu
quand même bon allez on met du destop
dans l'évier bim bam boum et on part
sportif au monde où l intérêt de montrer
toi qui vient d'une autre planète
j'arrive pas à falaise accents voilà je
mélange tout les actions du monde va
retourner vers la bas ok mais on est sur
le bon chemin on va retourner en hauteur
l'abcès dans le petit truc de petits
spots l'indre qui on est et on était
bien et bête est morte est mort c'est
bon et c'est papa qui je te lever moi
mon père à mon gamin augure si alain au
krav maga ou tuera ce truc on le dépôt
sera et on vendra sa peau hyper cher sur
ebay il y aura toujours un méchoui pour
acheter sa jauge de charge
c'est pas possible il est fort le coup
j'entends pas dire attends vie de
faugères autre moteur faut que je trouve
intéressant je vais mourir might be ok
c'est bon là on essaye faute venir
toucher ce bois ça porte chance tu
devrais venir
il est pas loin il est pas loin [ __ ]
chantera me chier dessus mon gars je
deviens parano envoyé les deux points
vert sur la carte là et je pense qu'il a
entre les deux est on est des bois
d'amont va aller voir direct et un bruit
cinq sangliers c'est quoi ce bruit une
seule solution la manifestation non
allez voir une biche
[ __ ] attendant on va se marrer dans le
doute sa tête a tiré la lienne aucun
signe de lui fort mais c'est impossible
monga en fait vous devez vous mettre une
caméra 360 sur moi et que je me balade
ou sur le port et la c610 mois une prise
de lui qu a alors dénoncé cette [ __ ]
d'étagères et parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il nous a tapé c'était ici avec ces
sociétés james avait calmé son odeur de
celui qui veut pas qu'on mette la nôtre
que je peux le comprendre
malheureusement je suis pas d'accord tu
enfin 3 soit en hausse compris compte
pas pu y avait une chance de tuer mais
qu adrien petit bunker la mecque c'est
super ça ne m'a très peu car nous nous
choper le coût de tout doute la pire
gâchettes du monde ça va encore plus
super d'être là donc que dedans rien
fixent calanques lochte mali look
des fois ça marche une fois à la fin
c'est pointer pour avoir dit à mon gamin
revenant au campement il sera parti et
que la caravane tranquillement on va la
retrouver sur le bon coin de mains
[ __ ] [ __ ] quand je regarde la map
t'es un gros lâcheté un grand lâcher un
gros match aller mais qui commence à me
bender monga cette année-là nous
attaquer dès qu'on ne voit pas au nom
j'avais sorti fusil j'avais certes il
faisait super mer n'est pas loin du
campement la mecque
le campement est juste là les gars
oh c'est bon la chasse a été bonne
pourquoi chercher un alien quand on peut
buter un port allez c'est bon la chasse
est terminée
moi je me casse ont coincé shia
chasseurs [ __ ] d'alien sans déconner
c'est un écran noir c'est fini c'est la
fin on l'a pas eu
on l'a pas hulot l'a pas eue je suis
vénère dont nous faisions de la vidéo on
n'a pas réussi avant la lienne et en
plus on a tué une bête qui a finalement
nourrit la lienne as t'il fait pourquoi
on retrouve cette [ __ ] de maître à
trois mètres de là on avait buté moi
j'arrête d'achat c'est pas pour moi je
vois les choses qui a posté une vidéo
sur et que je fasse ça vous a plu c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas les eaux comme
d'habitude je suis dégouté je voulais
troupe buts et cet alien et en plus
c'est vraiment fou quoi tu marches et
autour d'un coup meilleure imitation du
youtube game voilà j'ai la haine ou on
appelle d'autres diplômes de chasseurs
pour la sterne échec à la 13e prochaine
oberson regarder portez vous bien de
chez tout le monde
[Musique]